hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll when
i wrote the big picture that book that i
wrote a few years ago one of the most
fun parts of the process to me was
tracing what happens to energy that we
get from the sun
through the atmosphere of the earth and
then into life here on earth you know i
always ask people when i give talks what
good is the sun to us here on earth with
the idea that probably they're thinking
we get energy from the sun which is true
but what is most important about the
energy is that it is in a low entropy
form it is useful energy so that low
entropy energy we get from the sun is
captured by plants or unicellular
organisms and then it is basically
bottled up in certain molecules which
then go on to be eaten roughly speaking
by other organisms and used as fuel so
once that energy is in the right
molecules and gets into animals and
other aerobic organisms it goes through
what is called the krebs cycle or the
citric acid cycle the krebs cycle is
kind of amazing it's basically the way
that we take the fuel stored in these
molecules and turn them into useful
energy in our bodies and amazingly it is
really really ubiquitous for life on
earth here which maybe is a hint that
there's something important about it and
not only is it of course important for
metabolism and so forth but it is
perhaps uniquely important for
metabolism so today's guest is nick lane
a very well known biochemist and writer
who is one of the world's experts on the
origin of life but we're talking mostly
in this podcast not about the origin of
life but about how life uses energy in
this krebs cycle in this citric acid
cycle that's important for figuring out
the origin of life because it is
possible it is conceivable we don't know
yet that the krebs cycle predates life
itself that it has a non-biological
origin and coming into existence in a
purely chemical way might have been one
of the crucial steps into the origin of
life so this is fun stuff uh nick is an
actual expert when i was writing my book
i was not an expert but i tried i
learned i talked to people etc uh you'll
learn a lot from his perspective on this
stuff and it's crucially important to
tackling some of these big questions
about why there is life at all so nick
has a new book out called transformer
the deep chemistry of life and death
which is about exactly this topic and
let me assure you if you're not familiar
he's a brilliant writer as well as
scientist okay occasional reminder that
here at mindscape we have a website uh
preposterousuniverse.compodcast where
you can get show notes and full
transcripts for all of the episodes and
you can also support mindscape by going
and becoming a patreon supporter at
patreon.com
sean m carroll that's where you go if
you're a patreon supporter you get to
ask the questions that we answer for the
ask me anything episodes and you get
ad-free versions of the podcast for you
know a dollar a podcast what better deal
are you gonna find than that that's
pretty awesome okay that's the
occasional reminder of the commercial
side of the venture so with that let's
go
[Music]
nick lane welcome to the mindscape
podcast pleasure thank you for the
invitation
you know we've had a couple of episodes
recently learning about either
life in general or human life in
particular
uh in the ancient world from modern dna
and that's a very sensible thing to do
but what we're doing here is a little
bit different i mean you're kind of like
not talking about dna in rna as much as
many other books on these subjects talk
about you want to talk about energy and
processes and so forth so i guess my
first question is should we even expect
to be able to say anything about the
origins of life just by studying the
processes today i mean clearly they've
changed a lot uh in the interim
yeah and it depends who you ask that
question to as to what kind of an answer
you get
yes it's a good question can we use life
as a guide to its own origin or is there
some kind of circularity to that
um
and
i think for the last 50 or 60 years
people have avoided that question and
used chemistry as a guide to life's
origin
and
if we if we use genes and we try and go
back to the first cells that we can
reconstruct from genes it was already a
complex cell with
well with genes and with dna and
proteins and you know there's got
nothing to do with the origin of life
so
it's a genuine question but there's
there's a really interesting thing about
how do these complex metabolic pathways
arise in the first place and if they
there's one way of seeing you could say
well they they evolve step by step
and if that's the case
then you have to have a gene for each
step and each intermediate has to do
something useful for you and it becomes
enormously complicated very quickly
whereas if what you assume is these
pathways are more or less just
spontaneous chemistry and should happen
anyway in the right environment then all
the genes really need to do when they
emerge is just speed up processes that
are happening anyway in any which way
you want it to do that and so it
basically thinking the the the
basic metabolic pathways of life is just
spontaneous chemistry in the right
environment
really solves a lot of problems no
that's actually a very interesting point
even though i've talked to you and other
people about this stuff many times
before that never quite sunk in so
whenever you have a process that is
governed by evolution it works
incrementally right it you know it
starts with something and then so you
ask a question like what good is half of
a wing but the answer is evolved for
something else and then it made it there
so quarter of a wing yeah yeah what good
is that but so so for these metabolic
pathways what you're saying is we can
sort of
sidestep that problem entirely because
maybe they just all happen spontaneously
it's not that you know you're building
up the whole pathway piece by piece if
you start with chemistry
as as the whole field has done for for
decades
and you're guided by the chemistry
itself
what you end up with
is a kind of a soup the primordial soup
the famous primordial soup and you've
got amino acids and you've got
nucleotides you've got the building
blocks of life floating around in this
soup
um
and and then what happens next well
somehow it polymerizes and you end up
with dna or rna or something and then
somehow
uh information appears
it's there's a problem with the origin
of information if you see the origin of
life this way and then you have genes
and they invent metabolism
and so
there's a lot to my mind there's a lot
of jarring problems there whereas if
one of the biggest ones is the chemistry
that actually has worked well over
decades doesn't look anything like
life's chemistry as we know it
and so it forces there to be this
inventiveness of genes at an early stage
because genes have to invent metabolism
as we know it because the processes that
gave rise to the building blocks
were nothing like metabolism as we know
it now the alternative way is as i say
you have this
spontaneous pathways that just happen
in the right environment which give rise
in the end to the building blocks of
genes to the nucleotides
and eventually they polymerize in that
environment now
that's not been a popular view and the
reason it's not been a popular view is
because the way that life does it is it
starts with co2 and hydrogen and they're
just not very reactive with each other
and so for decades
nobody really ever succeeded in doing
the experiments that show that this is
really possible but in the last five
years
a lot of people have started to take it
much more seriously and these
experiments are being done now and
what do we see we see exactly the the
molecules of the central metabolic
pathways we see the krebs cycle
intermediates we see the amino acids we
see basically life's chemistry all just
happening from co2 and hydrogen and it's
just gobsmackingly beautiful to watch
so this is uh since i'm not a chemistry
person at all uh the idea here is that
you have these molecules co2 and
hydrogen and in some
sense they would like to combine or they
would like to rearrange you know
make turn the hydrogen put hydrogen onto
the uh uh carbons but it there's no
simple way to get there but what
chemistry can do is allow you to sort of
uh catalyze it right with the right
condition yes
it's a physics problem really it's just
thermodynamics and kinetics
dynamically yes they want to react and
they want to make these organic
molecules and they do in all kinds of
different environments but there are
kinetic barriers to the reactions right
and really what life is doing is
lowering the kinetic barriers to
thermodynamically favored the reactions
that's kind of all it does good and this
is part of just to put it in the um
uh you know context for the people who
are listening there's a debate in origin
of life circles
metabolism first versus replication
first is that a fair way to
define the camps yes i mean it's it's
exactly how a lot of the field has seen
it i think in recent years people have
been trying to get away from these
slightly extreme camps and say oh
co-evolution they happened together
um but but yes it's a kind of
way of seeing the question
really
uh and and i suppose i would be in the
metabolism first camp on the grounds
that i want all this spontaneous
chemistry to happen but it's not really
that i'm saying
that life is about metabolism
obviously it needs genes and information
and i'm not sure that i would describe
these
these
proto-metabolic pathways that give rise
to the building blocks of life i
wouldn't describe that as life
i would just describe that as a
geochemistry in the the right
environment
um
and the people who say they want to have
genes first
well they've still got to make the
nucleotides they're still doing this
prebiotic chemistry first so it's really
where do you want to draw an arbitrary
line across a continuum yeah um and
and where you draw that line depends on
which camp
you're in but i think really there are
there aren't camps there there are there
are different ways of coming up with the
requirements that biology has and
information is obviously one of the
requirements genes is
obviously one of them the question is
what's
what's the easiest way to produce them
so that they can do something useful for
you and if you have some kind of proton
metabolism and genes are introduced into
that what do they do they speed up the
proton metabolism they make it better
than it was before and so they have a
purpose a use from the very beginning
yeah i think that i mean again this
might be unfair so correct me if i'm
wrong but you know the big picture
message that seems to be coming across
in not just your most recent book but
your previous one as well um
is about energy versus information and
information is something that is very
exciting these days lots of scientists
my own you know colleagues love
information theory and information is
physical and things like that and you're
pushing back on that a little bit saying
okay but let's not
make it all bloodless and forget about
the role of energy because energy is
kind of important here
i i think there are some serious
problems
in
biology if we only focus on the
information i think we will you know
it's not that i want to belittle it or
anything it's obviously it's essentially
important in biology but it's not the
only thing that's centrally important in
biology and
i i think if you if you think about the
other things that make up life which is
basically turning gases into matter
that's what's going on very often that's
called growth
uh and and it's a really simple question
but it's about physical chemistry it's
not something
that we can i mean you probably can
define it in informational terms but
it's easier just to think about it as
chemistry um
and that chemistry does again things
which we can think about in
informational terms like
self-organization
but it's much easier just to understand
you just put you put oil on water and
it's going to separate into two layers
the oily layer and the aqueous layer and
that's more or less how cell membranes
work and you're getting order out of
nothing
it's not out of nothing it's about it's
about the the thermodynamics of of
separation of two phases depending on
the molecular attractions between
between molecules
hydrophobic interactions or ionic bonds
or whatever it may be
is there an informational way of seeing
that i'm sure there is but it's
it's it's less easy to understand than
just the physical chemistry yeah no and
i think that it's always good to have
multiple perspectives on these things
and we'll see which actually leads us to
you know the breakthroughs but okay i
think this is enough for like the big
picture ground laying where we're coming
from stuff let's get our hands dirty a
little bit you you've written a book
about the krebs cycle which i i can just
imagine the uh reaction of your
publisher when you when you pitch this
idea
uh explain to us why the krebs cycle
well what is it and why should we care
right now okay it was partly uh well
there's two reasons one of them is
um
i am a biochemist and the krebs cycle is
is probably the single most iconic
pathway in all of biochemistry and it's
hated by almost all biochemists and
basically especially medical students
who have to do some biochemistry it it's
a kind of the perfect circle right at
the heart of all of metabolism and
nobody really understands it and people
are forced to memorize it and this is
one of the things that puts people off
biology for life or biochemistry um it's
just um
incredibly dull
and
and it's basically
the rearrangements of
bonds in molecules composed only of of
carbon and hydrogen and oxygen and and
half of these rearrangements seem
pointless what's what's
it it's it it really is a very very
difficult challenge i could see why my
publishers were were bothered by it now
why then would i even write a book about
it there's two reasons uh really i'm
from they're both ends of the book one
of them is and i have two laps
um
one of the labs is working on the origin
of life and the other lab is working
on fruit flies and mitochondria
now so the krebs cycle is basically
what's happening in our mitochondria
it's where we
are
um
stripping down food to generate energy
we're stripping the electrons out of
food we're passing them into respiration
uh where we're passing them onto oxygen
to produce water as a waste product and
so we're basically burning hydrogen in
oxygen and that's what's powering us and
it's the krebs cycle which is doing that
but it goes through this strange cycle
of lots of peculiar intermediate steps
which seem to be
just a waste of time to try and
understand and lots of people did it was
you know
discovered in the 1930s by hans krebs it
became dusty textbook biochemistry
people have to learn it and don't want
to know and forget it as soon as they
can
but in the 60s
there was a really funky discovery
at berkeley uh that
some bacteria living in deep sea
hydrothermal vents
do the krebs cycle backwards
so so what we're really doing in in the
krebs cycle is we are we're taking these
these carbon skeletons which are
composed of carbon hydrogen and oxygen
and we're stripping out the carbon and
the oxygen and putting it out as co2 and
we're pulling out the hydrogen and we're
burning the hydrogen with oxygen that's
generating our energy
and we're releasing water as a waste
product now what these bacteria are
doing in the deep sea hydrothermal vents
they're taking hydrogen that's bubbling
out of the ground and they're taking co2
dissolved in the oceans and they're
running the krebs cycle backwards
putting in a bit of energy
and they're making these carbon
skeletons
so this is the reverse krebs cycle
and it's basically turning gases into
the core molecules of life
and um it took 20 years before these
ideas were were really accepted um in
part because people were looking for the
genes for it and it was not so obvious
um
exactly how it worked and so on so so
now
move forward another 20 or 30 years from
when it was finally accepted
the chemistry at the origin of life we
start with hydrogen and co2 and what do
we get we get these krebs cycle
intermediates and we get almost all of
them forming
under a fairly simple set of conditions
and when you look at the mechanisms of
the chemistry basically if you if you if
you've got a carbon skeleton you want to
stick co2 onto it you get a krebs cycle
intermediate and you get another one and
another one and you you're building
longer and longer chains of these core
molecules you want to make an amino acid
you you you effectively just stick it
straight onto that the the nitrogen
straight on to where one of the oxygens
used to be and again it happens
spontaneously and and so the more we
look at it the more we realize that at
this end at the origin of life you're
starting with these gases that are
definitely present
in any hydrothermal system on the early
earth and you're making the core
molecules of biochemistry very directly
and then the other end of this whole
thing is to do with aging and cancer
and it turns out and it's turned out
over the last 10 years that
often in cancer the krebs cycle runs
backwards
um it doesn't it doesn't do the normal
thing really it basically
cancer cells and sometimes our own
bodies are basically fixing co2 taking
it out of the atmosphere and converting
it into
into these carbon skeletons and using
them for growth
um and powering growth that way we're
almost photosynthetic in that sense no
light involved but we're taking co2 from
from the atmosphere from our own bodies
and converting it into
uh the intermediates of metabolism
um
so so this has been a big step change in
what's going wrong with cancer
and my own group working on mitochondria
are looking at that and so i've got two
groups who are both trying in the lab to
analyze these krebs cycle intermediates
both with completely different questions
in their mind and
just for my own sanity i have to try and
put it all together and say well hang on
a minute they've got to be related
but labs unlike uh chemical pathways do
not grow up spontaneously you must have
had some inkling that there were similar
things involved in these two projects
yes uh
i have and it's been building for a
while but it's really the similar things
is really to do with energy flow
in in my own mind at least so so so this
is
why it is that cells generate energy by
electrical charges on membranes and
that's what's happening in mitochondria
and actually that's what's happening in
some of these deep sea hydrothermal
vents is you have barriers with a
natural electrical charge on them and
you ask the question so what is this
charge doing
and the answer is in invents well it's
powering the reaction between hydrogen
and co2 to make krebs cycle intermediate
and so the krebs cycle has come into it
gradually through the back door you
might say yeah my primary questions were
to do with energy generation
um
but then you ask well what's the energy
doing and you end up uh thinking about
the krebs cycle and and it's very
strange the way that it's kind of
infiltrated into its way into my
thinking and not just me there's there's
plenty of people thinking along these
lines around the world now as well so
it's quite exciting so let me think
about this as a physicist because i'm
trying to figure out you know why things
are like this i mean uh when we talk
about
energy and how we use it the most basic
thing to do is have some fuel source and
burn it right like in our car we put in
gasoline and what's really happening
there is that there's energy locked up
in the fuel source and we're releasing
it by some chemistry that makes sense to
me and but there's no cycles involved in
that so in a cycle somehow you're taking
various combinations of of chemicals as
you said
carbon hydrogen oxygen and by slightly
changing you know the conditions you're
slightly raising and lowering the amount
of energy that these guys have and sort
of nudging the energy around a circle so
what what's the point of that why are
you doing something so complicated
rather than just uh burning some fuel
like my car does
yeah i mean there's two answers to that
one of them is surprisingly at the
origin of life it's everything's upside
down um and we're not actually burning
fuel the fuel is being supplied by the
planet the fuel is the hydrogen gas
bubbling straight out of the planet
with a disequilibrium with co2 in the
oceans now thermodynamically they want
to react together
um and and um the question there is
really more about the kinetic barriers
that prevent them from from reacting but
there's there is a physics question here
as well that goes back to harold
morovitz who who uh people have talked
about the fourth law of thermodynamics
and i think his snappy phrase for it was
energy flows and mata cycles
because nothing
nothing um
energy transfer is never is never
perfect so
you're always going to increase entropy
and that means you can never do a
perfect uh
reverse of any any specific reaction and
so photosynthesis and respiration are
kind of
opposite and equal processors but not
fully actually mata is cycling through
these two processes
i don't know if this is a profound
insight or if it's kind of a statement
to the obvious i'm not i can't i really
can't tell but it was beautifully put
anyway by by morovitz and and um
he saw the krebs cycle this was back in
the
back in the
in the late 60s i think he saw the krebs
cycle was kind of necessary
thermodynamically that mata is going to
cycle and that's why he pulled it out
as um as something important
and there were lots of protests at the
time and it i i think by the early 2000s
the ideas were beginning to die mostly
because nobody had succeeded in
reproducing it in the lab
and now people have started reproducing
it in the lab and ironically not as a
cycle but as as kind of straight line
pathways of a handful of intermediates
um so
i'm not sure his ideas are fully
vindicated yet but the the the kind of
the thermodynamic drivers behind it
definitely are i mean let's be a little
bit more specific about that because um
yeah i think this is this is crucial
because you've mentioned a couple times
uh the hydrogen and the carbon dioxide
uh they want to burn and then the
specific
uh maybe this is these well they want to
make organic molecules
they want to become you know krebs cycle
intermediates basically that's
thermodynamically the low energy state
i've gotten a lot of mileage out of our
friend michael russell's line that the
purpose of life is to hydrogenate carbon
dioxide uh and yes and the way i
interpret that is uh there's a barrier i
mean explain maybe you should do this
rather than me explain what you mean by
a barrier why can't they just rearrange
into a lower energy state
well i mean you put them together in a
test tube uh hydrogen and co2 and you
you warm up let's say warm it up to 100
degrees centigrade and let's put a
catalyst in there and and shake it up
and let it get on with it and what
happens
well nothing happens
um and and that's the problem right um
they're stable molecules
uh and that they're they're just not
easily going to react and this is why
chemists a long time ago dropped this
problem now it's coming back at least in
part because we have serious problems
with uh with the climate emergency and
co2 and global warming and so on uh and
with
energy um
security so what happened if you were
able to strip co2 out of the atmosphere
split water to make how to produce
hydrogen react the hydrogen with the co2
and make synthetic gasoline there's a
nice solution but that's basically what
life is doing
um and so there's been a a a a big
increase in the last few years in the
chemistry of co2 and hydrogen and it's
brought this problem you know nothing to
do with the origin of life but it's made
it more respectable again to think about
well
how how can we make them react and then
you know you think well okay life makes
them react all the time what is life
actually doing how is it making them
less stable more reactive
and the answer is in my view at least
well life is not chemistry in a bucket
it's is in a cell and what's happening
in the cell well it's the difference
between the inside and the outside of
the cell
um
is is the difference between the living
thing in the outside world but if you're
dealing with a single cell
what is the difference you've got a
membrane it's five nanometers thick five
millionths of a millimeter in thickness
and on one side of it you've got one set
of conditions which is inside the cell
and the other side you've got the
outside world
but but really all that membrane can
tell is you've got some ions on this
side and different ions on that side and
well what are they what are they doing
well the answer is they're producing a
charge on that membrane an electrical
charge and if you shrink yourself down
to the size of a molecule it's
equivalent to a bolt of lightning it's
got the it's it's about 30 million volts
per meter
is the is is the field strength that you
would experience if you were in in that
field
um
so what is that doing
well what is doing in modern cells is
all kinds of funky things with molecular
machinery made from proteins and so on
and
none of it's relevant to the origin of
life you think well
actually some
hydrothermal systems mimic this thing
where we've got a barrier and we've got
fluids with different compositions on
opposite sides of the barrier which
generate a natural charge
what could that charge do for us and the
answer is
it can
make hydrogen more reactive and it can
make co2 more reactive so long as
they're in separate phases
uh and if they can then be somehow
brought together across the barrier
across the membrane
then you can make them react uh and
that's effectively what life is doing
and the question for me in a prebiotic
chemistry point of view is if we don't
have just bucket chemistry going on but
we've got some structure
can that structure and the charges
involved in this in the two separate
phases can that drive
this reaction between hydrogen and co2
to make
the organic molecules and drive in
effect growth you're
converting hydrogen co2 in the
environment into more of
good i think that's a good thing or not
always a good thing i suppose there's
too much of me already but
i wonder we can tempest our way out of
that but um so at a very very basic
level in are all cells
what is the arrangement of charges are
they positively charged inside and
there's a negative charge on the cell
wall or is it usually positive it's
usually positive outside okay and the
way that cells work now
um is is by pumping protons so protons
are the the nucleus of hydrogen atoms
and they have a positive charge and and
what we're doing in our own mitochondria
is we pump them out and bacteria are
doing exactly the same thing they pump
from from the inside of the cell to the
outside uh and so you have a positive
charge on the outside of the cell and a
relatively negative charge on the inside
of the cell and what we have in these
hydrothermal vents is is acidic oceans
full of protons and alkaline fluids
bubbling into these vents which is
uh lacking protons
uh and and so it's it's not that there's
there's really
an overall electrical charge it's that
there's a difference in the proton
concentration between the outside and
the inside and they're going to flow in
uh and and so it's really the ph
gradient which is potentially driving
things at the origin of life
i mean just as a physicist i want charge
to be conserved so you can't pump out
protons forever somehow either you have
to pump out an electron or a proton has
to come back no well they flow back in
again okay so in in modern cells you
pump them out and then they come through
a turbine yeah like the atp synthase or
something like that and it powers work
so we're burning we're burning foods in
our own mitochondria
the energy released pumps protons across
the barrier to charge up the barrier and
then that charged barrier is is
propelling their flux back through
machinery in in the membrane through
these turbines like the atp synthase
plenty of other proteins though that
they work through so it's it's powering
work and in the modern biology the
modern cell
contemporary cells this will be very
very
complicated and intricate but from
everything you're saying it does make
sense how you know focusing on the
energy flow
gives you a similarity between what's
happening at the cell wall and what
might happen in a completely inorganic
thing in chemistry underneath the ocean
yeah i i think i was i misled myself for
a long time because i was thinking
i think
much more strictly in terms of energy
and what i what you think about with
mitochondria in terms of energy is atp
is the universal energy currency people
talk about in cells
and the atp synthase is this amazing
rotating motor that sits in the membrane
and is powered by the flux of protons
and it kind of cranks it cranks around
and
makes atp and it's it's um it's an
astonishing
protein amazingly sophisticated and you
think okay so so can i imagine you were
saying you were saying earlier on what's
what's half an atp synthase useful for
and the answer is well i can't imagine
half an atp synthase i can't imagine a
prebiotic version of it i i you know
it's plainly a product of genes right
and natural selection
um
in which case then you think okay well
what what could a natural gradient have
been useful for then if you already need
genes before you can use it so is there
something simpler
that it might power that a kind of
continuous influx of protons might power
something and it took me a long time to
put atp out of my mind and realize well
hang on a minute
what we're really dealing with in in in
growth in in turning gases in the
environment into more of me
um
where where we're really trying to
to make more of me we're trying we're
trying to lower that kinetic barrier to
the gases reacting to hydrogen and co2
reacting with each other to make organic
molecules
and in photosynthesis
and in in plenty of bacteria the
bacteria for example that are doing this
reverse version of the krebs cycle while
they're using they're using the
electrical charge and the proton
gradient the inflow of protons directly
to to drive this reaction between co2
and hydrogen so you think well could
that happen prebiotically and here we
don't need a turbine and we don't need
genes we're dealing just with physical
chemistry and it's it's actually it's to
do with the nursed equation but i won't
go into that but in effect if you've got
hydrogen
in an alkaline environment
and
you want it you want it to react which
means you want to pass its electrons
onto something else what's left behind
the protons are left behind and protons
are acidic
and they're in an alkaline environment
they're going to react with the
hydroxide ions to form water
and and so this is going to be really
favored in an alkaline environment
you're going to have a you know a lot of
people might remember doing
neutralization reactions acid-base
neutralization even in your mouth and
you guys fizzing reaction going on in
your mouth it's it's spontaneous
chemistry it's about it's unstoppable um
and so you have hydrogen in this
alkaline environment it passes its
electrons onto something else onto the
barrier let's say and now you've got
protons reacting with hydroxide ions
with this unstoppable reaction if you
put in if you put the hydrogen in an
acidic environment and try and do the
same thing well now you're you're making
acid inside an acid environment it's
zero it's not it's not trying to work
yeah so hydrogen's reactive in alkaline
solution co2
if you want to make it react well first
it has to pick up an electron and now
it's got a negative charge how does it
balance the charge well if there's a
proton handy right next to you in an
acidic environment pick that up now you
balance the charge and now you take
another electron now you take another
proton it becomes much more reactive in
an acidic environment and so what you
need
is hydrogen in one for an alkaline phase
and co2 in an acidic phase
and there has to be those two phases
have to be juxtaposed right next to each
other so that there can be a transfer of
stuff and the stuff that has to be
transferred is electrons
from one phase to the other face
and a semiconducting barrier will
transfer those electrons from one phase
to the other phase and that's
effectively what the cell membrane is
today and it's effectively what these
barriers are in vents they're
they're they're separate they're
semiconductors between two separate
phases okay let me see if i can
reconstruct what's going on here because
it does sound it makes sense when you
say it
so we have all this energy locked up in
co2 and hydrogen uh but you just put
them in a little bucket and they don't
react they're too stable they're too
happy all by themselves
but if we can segregate them a little
bit uh and put one in an acidic
environment and one in an alkaline
environment then they become much more
ready to
release their energy to react in the
right way to do to let that energy go
and so you need that kind of
separation a kind of barrier a kind of
membrane uh you need acid and alkaline
and uh
you need the proton gradient as as you
said and then
the idea would be i suppose that these
reactions that have been enabled by this
simple setup
keep going and maybe grow and become
more sophisticated as as they they go
from being some inorganic chemistry to
being life
yes all i'm really trying to do is
preserve the same topology as a cell so
what you have in these in these vents is
really a labyrinth of pores
cell-like pores with a with a thin
inorganic barrier surrounding them and
at least in my imagination is you know
these a lot of these are down at the
bottom of the ocean and not easy to get
at but we can we can do experiments in
the lab using microfluidic chips and
things like that and and
and show that this kind of thing is at
least possible
that uh on the inside of the pore you
have your alkaline fluids on the outside
you have your acidic fluids and and the
barrier between the two
let's say that electrons or protons can
cross that barrier and and that's been
shown to happen which means you have
separate phases mike russell uses the
phrase frustration the mixing is
frustrated it's slowed down
but it happens anyway but the rate at
which the fluids are replenished with
hydrothermal flow or ocean waters
percolating in is faster if you like
than the rate of mixing okay and so
you're cons you've constantly kept your
two phases so the planet is doing the
work
it's really it's gravity in the end that
takes the iron down and puts the
hydrogen coming from the earth and the
co2 in
so so so the planet is a giant battery
it's like a giant cell
where
the inside is alkaline relative to the
outside
um
and the way that the topology of cells
is very similar to the topology of the
planet and the way that they function is
very similar to at a micro level what
you're seeing inside these vents but
it's a it's a beautiful idea that really
cells mimic the structure of the planet
and just to be again clear to the
non-experts here this is in contrast
with what has been i guess the dominant
view or at least sort of the default
view almost since darwin where he talked
about like a little warm pond and you
would have just all these chemicals and
they would be complicated enough and and
life would start and what you're
emphasizing is you you can't just put
chemicals in a bucket you need the
separation of different phases across a
membrane
and that kind of chemistry that we see
in life can be mimicked in certain
environments but not a pond maybe an
underwater alkaline vent
uh to my mind an underwater alkaline
vent there there are some of these vents
on the surface as well uh so it's uh
it's possible but it's it's much harder
to have
if you've got a if you've got a
let's say yellowstone or something like
that
um
or or there are uh the cedars for
example in northern california that's a
serpentinizing system which is to say
it's the same it's the same type of
system as the deep sea vents but it's on
land but it provides some interesting
problems because what you see then is
this process of serpentinization
produces alkaline fluids so alkaline
fluids come bubbling up through the
ground and they form a pool at the
surface
and the pool is alkaline
and uh there are no proton gradients
there because there's no it's not going
into an ocean which is acidic in the
early on the early earth now there's a
guy called ken nielsen who's done some
beautiful work on the cedars and he was
perplexed because there are these
bacteria
that grow there
um
and he thought well
how were they doing it they had a normal
functional atpase
so they were able to gen but but
normally it pumps protons there aren't
any protons in this environment because
it's only alkaline so how do they do it
you thought perhaps they pump sodium
ions but it's a freshwater environment
they don't pump sodium either there's no
sodium there so he thought maybe it's
something funky maybe it's calcium ions
that they're pumping or something really
weird um no it turns out they pump
protons
how do where do they get the proteins
from they get them from the hydrogen gas
that's bubbling straight out so they're
taking them from and they pump them out
of the cell but they're growing where do
they get their co2 from
co2 doesn't dissolve in alkaline fluids
so there's really starved of carbon
but if you squirt acid onto carbonates
then you dissolve the carbonate and you
get your co2 that way so they take the
protons from from the hydrogen gas and
they squirt them onto the carbonate
surrounding and dissolve the carbonate
and get the co2 that way so they
actually function as completely normal
cells but they're doing it in quite a
complicated way
so the reason i'm telling you those
complications is you think about life
starting in a terrestrial geothermal
system
and these gradients are not easy to come
by
the nice thing about having an ocean
setting even if it's a shallow ocean
is that we have gradients we have uh you
know
alkaline water going into an acidic
system you don't really get that on land
and you can use the sort of reasoning on
the basis of chemistry and energetics uh
to predict exactly what kind of
environment you need and we've even
found the environments right in places
like lost city
yeah there's the strong counter argument
to it has been that uh it's all
hypothetical that none of this chemistry
actually works and that the chemistry
starting with cyanide and uv radiation
really works and we've done it in the
lab and that argument is getting weaker
as time goes by because you know we and
others um people like
joe moran um martina pryner and so on
have been doing this chemistry in the
lab for the last five or six years um
and and it really works you can start
with hydrogen and co2 and make the krebs
cycle intermediates
people are trying to make nucleotides
that way now the building blocks of dna
it's not
so easy but you know watch this spot
within within six months or a year there
will be papers showing nucleotide
synthesis starting that way wow okay
that's very cool i mean i could i want
to get there let's let's put a pin in
that but i i want to build up a little
bit because i i get the
analogy or the similarities between the
energetics inside cells and the
energetic in these vents or similar
things where there is some kind of
membrane some kind of gradient some kind
of
acid alkaline uh division but how does
that become a cell how does it how does
that evolve into something we'd
recognize as living what where is the
point at which you replace this
inorganic barrier with something we
would recognize as a cell membrane
well it's it's actually in a way
surprisingly easy because what do we
what are we what are we doing here where
we're using the barrier and the
gradients to drive the reaction between
co2 and hydrogen to make
to make organic molecules
some of the easiest organic molecules to
make under those conditions are
longish chain meaning 10 to 15 carbons
fatty acids or fatty alcohols or simple
hydrocarbons
and what do they do well they go through
a standard phase transition
and they um
if you if you have the
if you have the
especially the fatty acids
they have a charged head group and that
charged head group means that they
will form a membrane very much like a
bilayer membrane surrounding cells
and we've done some work that shows that
you form what we kind of optimistically
call protocells because they're
basically it's a bilayer membrane
surrounding an aqueous space that
aqueous base has got nothing in it it's
not a cell in any meaningful sense of
the word except that it's got a barrier
around it which is very much like a cell
membrane
except that it's only made from fatty
acids and fatty alcohol so long chain
long chain meaning 10 to 15 carbons in a
chain the kind of things that have been
made in those environments spontaneously
form cells now what happens to those
cells well they like to just stick to
the barrier
and if they just sit there and stick to
the barrier then whatever's crossing
that barrier is going to go into the
cells as well
and so the question then is well
can you use the same gradients across
the barrier and the cell to drive the
growth of the cell
um can can that cell now make two cells
and so on right and we've not really
shown that yet but in principle it
should happen
and and if it does then then you've
effectively got the natural gradients
driving
the growth and replication of protocells
just through converting gases into
into the fatty acids that you need
good so let me again try to summarize
and and you can tell me where i'm wrong
here because i have i've even written
about this stuff in the big the big
picture so i have some vague
recollection of what's going on if we
think of life as requiring
compartmentalization right the cell wall
metabolism as we talked about and also
uh information the dna or rna whatever
my impression is that that
compartmentalization that cell wall part
of it that's the easy part which is
basically what you just it's a cell
membrane i'm talking about rather than
the cell wall oh i don't even know that
there's a difference the cell membrane
is really thin and it's made of these
oily things so fatty acids and so on the
cell wall
is much more robust but it's not really
compartmentalizing things it's providing
a kind of rigid structure cell membrane
okay now
that's
later to my mind to make a to make a
bilayer membrane is it turns out to be a
bit like mixing oil and water it's not
necessarily any more difficult than that
right um so it will form spontaneously
and the the very interesting thing that
you just added to that is this idea that
because these membranes do form
spontaneously if they're right there in
this environment where you have these
disequilibria these differences between
alkaline acid they can kind of inherit
them they can pick that up pretty
quickly and uh and become
uh you know places where that metabolism
can happen
yeah uh we i mean that's the hope
you you you've touched on
the kind of the key point i think in how
do you go from a purely inorganic system
to a cell which is basically doing the
same thing yeah um and for that to
happen
you you need to have a some kind of
transition where instead of having a big
mineral surface which is which is
driving this reaction
instead it's happening over the membrane
itself so what would you need to have
sitting in that membrane for the same
thing to be going on and the answer is
well what what what does it today and
and the answer is iron sulfur proteins
okay so what's an iron sulfur protein an
ion sulfur protein has got a little
cluster of iron ferric and ferrous iron
so iron iron2 and iron3 and and sulfide
um maybe
four of them four ions four sulfurs or
sometimes two or sometimes three but
they're they're very small clusters and
they're always in in proteins they're
always bound by an amino acid called
cysteine
um
we've all we've shown relatively
recently that if you just mix iron and
sulfur and
cysteine
in water at alkaline ph you
spontaneously form these uh iron sulfur
clusters
and they have a structure which is quite
similar to the mineral grygite
which is part of the composition of
these barriers that are doing so so
we've effectively we've just sequestered
a little bit of this mineral surface
with a single amino acid no polymers
here at the moment so this entire system
all the membrane itself is not made of
polymers it's just made of fatty acids
we have a we have iron sulfur clusters
bound by cysteine which
in principle could sit near the membrane
and drive co2
uh reduction
in practice it's really hard to show
that we're kind of stuck
trying to demonstrate but in in
principle you can imagine that they
maybe they kind of stick to the membrane
and then they can drive co2 fixation
inside the protocell so now you've got
an autotrophic protocell which is going
to grow because it's going to make new
organics inside itself rather than
collecting them from the environment uh
so there's a lot you know there's a lot
of gaps there that we need to fill in
but yeah principal if you've got
autotrophic growing protocells then
you've got the perfect environment later
on for introducing genes and don't take
this the wrong way but you're absolutely
reminding me of why i do not want to be
a chemist or a biologist
there's just too many
too many things too many chemicals too
many atoms i just like a small number of
electrons and protons and neutrons keep
me happy it's a real problem with both
biology and chemistry and i i think i
i've kind of learned that the physicists
mindset is is very opposed to much yes
to
chemistry and biology
uh and and and on the other way around
most biologists
really struggle with physics and and to
my mind
you know the answer is between physics
chemistry and biology and and unless
unless you know i attempt to wrestle
with physique i'm not a good physicist
but i i love physics uh and and i you
know i struggle
i struggle with the physics but unless i
unless i make the effort to to do it
most of what i've been talking about is
actually a problem in physics more than
oh yeah than in biology yeah yeah well i
mean how do you structure matter exactly
that's what makes it fun because there
are these general principles of energy
flow and entropy increase and and
information
but in the context of these very very
specific properties of all the different
atoms and molecules that we care about i
mean that's what that's why it's uh both
intellectually challenging but rewarding
when you figure it out
yeah and i think um
i do want to once again contrast slash
compare to what is maybe the more common
view in origin of life uh research
because we have this paradigm we haven't
even mentioned yet of the rna world
right where uh rna is a wonderful
molecule because it can hold information
like dna can but it's not quite as
stable so it's easier to sort of make
and break apart and it can do functional
things like proteins so a lot of people
really focus on creating rna as the
first step towards really understanding
life and you haven't even mentioned rna
yet so what
no well i mean that's
rna is clearly important and it's
central in how cells work today and i
think some form of an rna world
certainly
happened it's a necessary intermediate
step to get dna and to get to to to real
informational systems
um but but there's different
ways of imagining an rna world and it is
imagination because nobody's really you
know ever seen one or yeah and you can
create one by injecting a whole load of
nucleotides into a into a bottle but
where did all those nucleotides come
from so so the problem has been kind of
compartmentalized and we have the
synthetic chemists who say right you
want to have an rna world
before you can make rna you need to make
the building blocks the nucleotides and
my job is to make you the nucleotides uh
and i'm i'm a chemist i make new
nucleotides here's the way that works
best we start with cyanide in a
terrestrial geothermal system we have uv
radiation i can make you bucket loads of
nucleotides and now you guys you are an
a world guys you can you can
come up with with systems
auto catalytic systems that are going to
make copies of of
of rna
and once you've got a system which is
capable of making copies of itself then
it's going to become more sophisticated
and at some point it's going to say hey
well if i can use this ingredient from
the environment to help me make a copy
of myself i'm going to build on some
metabolism to to the way the whole thing
works
and
so that's the kind of the mainstream
concept at the moment so you you have
prebiotic chemistry makes you
nucleotides the nucleotides polymerize
in some favored environment wet dry
cycles is the usual one that people talk
about now you've got rna the rna does
its stuff and invents things and copies
itself and we've got natural selection
and that invents all of metabolism
and to my mind almost every step of that
is backwards
um
so so what do we what do we
where where would i introduce rna
um
what does what does life do well life
starts with co2 and hydrogen to make
krebs cycle intermediates from krebs
cycle intermediates it makes amino acids
and it makes sugars and all of that has
been done in the lab
to make nucleotides you take the amino
acids and you take sugar phosphates uh
and and you go through a bunch of steps
you know 10 steps or something um to get
the nucleotide building blocks for rna
so this is quite hard
uh it's a lot of steps and to propose
that this is going to happen
spontaneously
as
prebiotic chemistry takes a lot of
belief i i grant you i've had a phd
student working on these questions for
for a few years
he's making progress but we've not done
all of it but you know
we're talking
problems that last potentially for
decades
um
let's say it's successful
and we're in a we're in a we we're
already in a kind of protocell world
here because we've got we're making
we're making the fatty acids we're
making the krebs cycle intermediates
they're they're kind of like fatty acids
really um
so so so we have the spontaneous
organization we've got growing
autotrophic protocells as this term that
i was using before but you know
cell-like things that are growing
by by converting co2 and hydrogen into
more of themselves and
over time can you define the word
autotrophic
ah sorry yes so so it just means
growing from um instead of eating other
things you grow from gases
uh in the environment you grow from
inorganic molecules in the environment
okay like plants plants are autotrophic
they're growing from water and from co2
lots of bacteria are autotrophic and
they can grow perhaps from hydrogen or
hydrogen sulfide or something and carbon
dioxide it's very similar principles but
they're they're not growing from organic
molecules they're not they're not eating
things so heterotrophic is eating stuff
okay
so what these what these
early systems are doing then is of
turning inorganic gases into organic
molecules and they're growing
um
and
let's say they get better at doing it i
won't go into how we think that they can
get better at doing it but we think
there are basic physical mechanisms of
heredity that can make them better at
doing it but they see the positive
feedback loops
um
and
and we
we we end up with nucleotides that
polymerize again i'm hand waving here
we now have nucleotides inside our
protocells and they're going to
polymerize
so now we have rna we've introduced rna
quite late in these proceedings and that
it's been introduced into something
which is growing anyway
what's that rna going to do
um well it's going to improve protocell
growth one way or another
its success depends on you know
how how could it possibly do that well
it can do that by effectively templating
peptides proteins nascent proteins why
would it possibly do that well there are
patterns in the genetic code that
suggest there are biophysical
interactions between between the codons
or the anticodons the code itself
between the nucleotides and amino acids
that effectively they'll bind to each
other in one way or another it depends
on
their hydrophobicity how much they like
or dislike water their size there's
various
very very various principles they're
very difficult to show in the lab again
i've got people working on that and it's
slow business some people claim they've
succeeded other people don't believe
them
i really don't know but the patterns in
the code suggest it's
possible right so
we get a small
a small
um
string of rna
and it templates a small peptide onto it
what does that peptide do
well it has properties which are
physical properties either it's
hydrophobic or it's hydrophilic it wants
to be in the solution or it wants to be
in the membrane of a growing protocell
it's got those two phases right there
what's it going to do if it goes to the
membrane well it probably is going to
improve the way that
the protons come in and reduce co2 so
it's going to improve growth what's it
going to do if it sits there
in the cytosol chances are it's going to
interact with ions like magnesium
in which case physical chemistry says
it's going to come up with a structure
which looks a bit like the active site
of an enzyme such as the rna polymerase
enzyme which is what actually
polymerizes rna in modern cells
so we have functions right there which
depend only on physical chemistry
so
all we need to do is copy the rna yeah
and which is nothing but co2 yeah
okay so this is where the rna world is
in my in my i like it yeah okay so
you're blowing my mind here so i'm going
to try once again to uh repeat what you
just said in words i understand and and
you can
you can fix me um
you know biologists bless their hearts
they like to imagine that natural
selection is the wonderful mechanism
that improves things right improves
functions and so forth um but there are
other
mechanisms by which things improve
there's sort of optimization procedures
just purely physically or chemically or
you know energetically so what we're
what we're saying here is that you can
start with these primitive
uh
chemical reactions
protons flying across gradients et
cetera et cetera this can sort of
i mean there's a step here that i'm
missing which is a very basic one how
this grows into something like the krebs
cycle um
but it becomes a little bit more
dramatic and you know the krebs cycle
intermediaries as you've mentioned uh
become involved and one thing i think
maybe we glossed over is that in
addition to shuffling energy around the
krebs cycles responsible for making
amino acids is that a true statement
uh
yes not exactly responsible for making
them but basically they are
it's a single step to go from from from
a carboxylic acid which is to say a
krebs cycle intermediate to an amino
acid okay all you have to do is replace
one oxygen with uh ammonia or something
similar to ammonia so and it's it's that
oxygen that gets replaced is is a pretty
reactive oxygen it's an alpha keto
oxygen we don't need to worry about the
terms but basically it's going to react
with ammonia very quickly
and does
um and so you the first thing you get if
you react co2 and hydrogen is a krebs
cycle intermediate if you put ammonia
into that makes the next thing you get
is an amino acid
if you
um
if you
effectively steepen
if what you're doing is is um
you're relying on hydrogen reacting with
co2
um and
it's a very small proportion is going to
react let's say but it's tiny proportion
does and it's going to make
um
a few things including perhaps a couple
of amino acids what are those amino
acids going to do well they have
physical properties of their own they're
going to interact with other things
i said already they can interact with
iron and sulfur
um and to make iron sulfur clusters
cysteine will do that
what's that going to do is going to sit
in the membrane and it's going to
convert more hydrogen and co2 into
organic molecules
so we're effectively converting more of
this environmental disequilibrium into
more of me right right
and because these pathways should happen
spontaneously stuff should happen right
the way down the pathway and the more
you steepen that gradient the more of
central biochemistry you should get
right the way through to nucleotide
building blocks of dna right so that's
the basic idea is it's it's it's really
about steepening
the driving force through all of
proto-metabolism
by lowering the barrier to the reaction
between co2 and hydrogen right so
starting from this original co2 and
hydrogen desire to release their
energies uh we figured out chemistry
that makes that happen there's sort of a
byproduct that is amino acids which
leads also to other organic molecules
and eventually even to rna rna bases
which can then uh gang up and then
there's this fun step which i'm not
quite sure i understand where just
having rna around lets you optimize the
rest of the energetics in some sense
right i mean the rna can kind of
organize things and maybe what you have
with with let's what you would have in
the in
we've got a population of protocells
that are all growing and making copies
of themselves and we put rna we have rna
now inside it and we've got a load of
random sequences of rna
um so there's no information it's just
random sequences but those random
sequences are capable of plating
peptides non-randomly so this random
sequence
is going to have a non-random peptide on
it because the peptide that you form on
that sequence depends on the sequence
even though the sequence is random it's
going to define
the
the the amino acids in that peptide so
so it's a non-random interaction there
and now we've got a population of these
things all producing random rnas with
non-random peptides that can do some
form of work what kind of work can they
do in this environment well there's this
you know the work which is going to be
useful for a protocell is to make more
protocell
okay
convert more co2 into more into
and if if all of this whole system is
capable of regenerating itself because
all it is is just thermodynamics and the
entire system is going to happen
spontaneously so long as the catalysts
are there you will go right the way
through and you'll make more copies of
yourself right
so
so we have natural as soon as you have a
random sequence of rna
in a growing protocell world
then we've got information and meaning
because that
the meaning is coming from the context
and the context is cell growth
so genes are introduced into a world of
growing cells from the very beginning
which is all they've ever done
yeah so the rna was not it's not like
rna came into existence and and
whipped up some cell membranes etc it
said rna you know found itself in this
environment with protocell membranes and
started i don't want to speak too
teleologically here but it started to
optimize things it started to fine-tune
things in ways that were
trying to make more of itself trying to
abet this reaction that is going on but
we've cut out all the problem about how
how is it going to invent information
from nothing the answer is it doesn't
need to um
all it needs to do is be a non-random
template for peptides which have
function in the context of growing
protocells and as soon as you've got all
that lot together
then the whole information problem in
biology just evaporates
yeah no i'm very very sympathetic to
that i've been thinking along similar
with uh lines myself but
okay i we're a long way from modern day
life so and you know we want to get to
cancer and aging at some point so and
let's accelerate ourselves because none
of this stuff that we're talking about
right now
in that protocells or the very very
earliest cells has anything that we
would recognize as mitochondria right
mitochondria were swallowed up
yeah so so where do mitochondria come in
because that's where the krebs cycle
happens these days yeah
well the krebs cycle happens in our
mitochondria but it'll but mitochondria
were bacteria once
and bacteria have their own krebs cycle
and and bacterial krebs cycle in in
in an oxygenated environment works
exactly the same way that ours does
uh it's effectively burning hydrogen in
oxygen to to generate energy but if you
put these bacteria in a in a deep sea
hydrothermal vent then everything goes
in the opposite direction and the krebs
cycle is in reverse and it's actually
taking hydrogen co2 and making organic
molecules so we've got a long history of
the
of the planet which started out four
billion years ago
with no oxygen in the atmosphere and
ends up sometime around the cambrian
explosion where animals first appear
where oxygen levels were approaching
modern levels
almost certainly um and we've got a we
we've got all of this spontaneous
chemistry going on which is going to
depend really on the environment that is
in
and so the direction when the krebs
cycle either goes backwards or forwards
or it
depends on the environment so ours goes
more or less forwards from our own point
of view we're burning hydrogen and
oxygen to generate energy
but if you have an anoxic environment or
a hydrothermal system it's doing exactly
the opposite of that it's taking
hydrogen co2 to make organic molecules
and so you have this very interesting
question about the history of life on
earth about
what happens to those cells where it
suddenly flips and the answer is well it
probably doesn't suddenly flip there are
various
the idea that it's a perfect circle is
almost certainly wrong there's all kinds
of different ways that it can operate
including a kind of two-pronged version
of the krebs cycle um so it's not a
cycle in some sense just calling it a
cycle is already misleading there's
something platonic perfection about it
and it's really not yeah um
it's just doing
these two jobs that it always did it's
producing hydrogen to burn
and it's it's on the one hand or it's
taking hydrogen and sticking it onto co2
to make organic molecules
and it can do either at any time it just
depends on the environment it's in let
me just make a statement rather than
asking a question then you can react to
the statement because we've been talking
about energy flow right
part of me as a physicist again wants to
say
but really it's not energy it's entropy
that is doing the work here because
energy is just conserved it's the same
amount but you have free energy you have
energy locked up in some low entropy
form in this case the co2 and the
hydrogen and you're increasing entropy
by uh you're finding a way to increase
the entropy to lower the free energy and
you know i just want to make this
statement because it is part of my you
know you're absolutely right i use the
term energy very loosely yeah and i mean
free energy most of the time when i'm
talking about energy um and as far as
entropy is concerned i think this is you
know one potential difference between
the kind of physical chemistry that i've
talked about and shannon entropy
informational type entropy
if you mix oil and water
um
then you get the two phases
which form spontaneously that's some
form of order that you're getting from
from that why is it happening
spontaneously well it's happening
spontaneously because
the the oil is hydrophobic and doesn't
like water and
it is effectively releasing
it's a more stable state if it's
separated
and the energy difference is heat right
which is increasing the entropy in the
surroundings so when oil and water
separate entropy increases the overall
energy of the universe increases as a
result of that separation and if we
think about cells
we see exactly the same things a protein
folds in on itself so the hydrophobic
bits that don't like water go on the
inside and the hydrophilic bits that
like water go on the outside
so it's actually a low energy state
it releases energy as it falls in that
way and so it increases entropy so
everything's being driven by entropy
increasing in the universe
but it's really being driven by the
physical chemistry of hydrophobic and
hydrophilic interactions of things now i
don't know that there is really an
equivalent in shannon entropy
to that in purely informational terms is
you tell me i'm out of my depth with
that you know i i would say that there
probably is i would need to go through
the details but the point is that that
imagine the race as long as you're
generating heat what what's happening is
you're not keeping track of all the
degrees of freedom that you you count as
heat right you know the the motions of
the molecules or even infrared photons
that you're giving off and you're sort
of carrying away information in those so
you're only paying attention to some
subset of the whole system so it looks
like it's becoming more orderly but as
you already said the universe is
becoming less orderly so the the shannon
entropy is also going up i think
but
the reason why i like to emphasize this
is because i'm always hearing people
lamenting the second law of
thermodynamics oh everything's running
down entropy is increasing isn't it sad
and i i want to emphasize that we're
only here because that v is increasing
like we should be celebrating the second
law of thermodynamics not limiting it
well there would be no life without it
exactly that that's right
okay so the uh the mitochondria good we
we've are our cells i mean and maybe
talk about because this is always a
crucial question for exobiology uh it
did take a while right for um
it's different cells to symbiotically
absorb other kinds of cells and now we
call them mitochondria and it did take
some time and we're not sure why like
roughly speaking
some protobiotic chemistry happened
pretty early but this this absorption
took a lot longer and then the
eukaryotic transition also
yeah so
so so all the prebiotic chemistry we've
been talking about so far
is basically is it's just chemistry and
it should happen spontaneously it should
happen in nanoseconds you know the time
scale is not millions of years the time
scale is nanoseconds or picoseconds or
something um
and and
it doesn't i mean there's a lot of
complexity there but it doesn't strike
me as necessarily
that difficult
i don't you know we've got as far as as
strands of rna and now as soon as that
can copy itself we have natural
selection and
the world's your oyster really um so i
don't think
the origin of life is necessarily that
serious a problem on a planetary scale
um and i suppose nobody would be working
on it if it was because
you know the idea is we can do it in the
lab we can solve this problem at least
we can understand how it might happen
but then you know from from from a
biologist or a geologist's point of view
there was a long gap of more than two
billion years before we see complex
eukaryotic cells so that's our own type
of cell which we've got mitochondria and
they've got a large nucleus with lots of
dna
and
it's
we are very closely related to plants
and to mushrooms and
other eukaryotic cells so plainly we
share a common ancestor and by
definition a common ancestor arises once
so you could say well maybe there were
thousands of separate origins of complex
things and they all just disappeared
and that might be true
but it's also possible it only happened
once and the only evidence we have is
that all the complex life we see around
us is closely related and and shares a
common ancestry by definition only
happen once so if it happened on
thousands of occasions then we ought to
see something in the fossil record we
ought to see if we look in strange
environments maybe we'll find something
we never have we've been looking for a
long time so
you can turn the question on its head
and say okay well
let's say it did happen once
why would it only happen once what are
the and the thing about again an
informational
context
you know it's basically from the genes
and the information that we know that it
happened once so so again i'm not
knocking genes but if you think about
the genetic variation in bacteria or in
archaea it dwarfs the amount of genetic
variation in eukaryotes they they've
explored genetic sequence space far more
thoroughly right than than eukaryotes
ever did and yet in their morphology
they remain small and simple and
stunning they've got amazing molecular
machines
but but they're always at the level of
the molecular machines they don't have
large bloated cells with lots of moving
parts in them lots of membranes lots of
structures inside
um so why
then would you have this step change
uh i i think the most beautiful answer
it may not be quite right but the the
answer is well you you had
some cells some bacterial cells getting
inside an archaeal host cells basically
something very similar to bacteria
and that that changes the topology of
what cells are instead of having a cell
membrane which is your interface with
the outer world which you're also using
to power everything because that's where
the charge is now we've internalized the
charge along with some genes which are
needed to control that charge
and you can now use your outer membrane
to do
anything else you no longer need it to
be charged in the same way you don't
need to have genes next to it in the
same way that bacteria do
so suddenly you've got a new structure
and over time without asking anything
other than normal natural selection the
bacteria living inside are going to get
smaller and simpler and throw away stuff
they don't need they're going to compete
with each other and they're going to end
up that's basically little power
stations optimized power stations
and the host cell is going to pick up
all this superfluous dna that's floating
around from these bacteria and it's got
more power than it knows what to deal do
with
um it's got these pesky
bacteria parasitic bacteria living
inside it that are probably going to eat
it if they have half a chance
so it's got to try to make sure it's
using them for something useful for
itself but but not being eaten and so
we've got a kind of a power struggle
going on a conflict of the interest
between the host cell and and
and the symbionts and it's a very
productive way of seeing selection to
say okay well number one it's not that
easy for one cell to get inside another
cell if these cells are tiny bacterial
things with a cell wall surrounding them
so that's rare
but we know of examples and then once
it's happened we've got this power
struggle going on
where it's more likely to end in failure
and extinction than it is in in in in a
fancy eukaryotic amazing system
so so this gives you a reason
why it only happened rarely it doesn't
say it had to happen once it just says
it's not going to happen all the time
and we only have evidence for it
happening once maybe it happened a few
times and they disappeared
but it also says why bacteria do not
become large and complex well they don't
become large and complex because they
don't have endo symbols they can't
restructure their energy generation in
the same way
they're basically stunted by their cell
structure
and and so we have this step change
where cells get inside cells and now we
have a kind of russian doll type set up
where
the whole
relationship between genes and energy
changes to a different format and that
changes everything that's possible it
effectively allows eukaryotic cells to
have a massive genome of nuclear genes
which allows you to do
to become multicellular it allows you to
you have all all the cells in your body
have got exactly the same genome
but your brain cells only use some of
those genes and your kidney cells use
different genes but if you made your
brain cell from bacteria with one type
of dna and your kidney cells from
another bacterial cell with a different
type of dna they'd fight
whereas if they're the same dna
they're the same cell type they don't
fight in the same way this is standard
evolutionary biology now um but to be
able to do that you need to have a large
genome in the first place there are
these cells switch on these genes and
off those genes and those ones switch
off these genes and on those genes and
so on you need a large genome and to do
that you need a power supply and
mitochondria are the power supply
so as soon as you've got a system which
is effectively capable of building
sophisticated bricks
you can build a sophisticated
multicellular organism then which is
capable of using those bricks to make
organs and whatever
so if we buy the
chemistry story that that you that you
laid out for the very origin of life
it's possible that that happened
multiple times all over the place i mean
you've said it it's actually kind of
easy and the time scale is short but in
contrast you're saying that there
probably was literally one cell that was
the first eukaryotic cell and we were
all descended from that
um not literally one cell but one
population of things okay snuggling up
to each other
uh probably some kind of trade going on
in raw materials between cells that are
snuggling up and you know one of them
gets inside another one it happens here
but it also happens in the guys over
there you know this is these are
processes that are happening we're
dealing with populations but it's it's
two populations of cells that are
interacting with each other in a
particular environment at a particular
time and it's that that gives rise to
these complex cells so we're not dealing
with this kind of singularity of one
cell gets inside one other cell and
and there's an amazing explosion we're
dealing with processes and populations
and the probability of these
these relationships happening so it is
kind of normal probabilistic science
it's not we're not talking miracles here
but we are talking about improbabilities
no absolutely
and it wouldn't be surprising if we
found life ubiquitous in the galaxy but
most of it was uh
just simple slimy celled organisms
that would be my best get yeah
which is a bit of a disappointing bet
you know we'll find out like
i would like it to be like hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy out there but uh
but
my own science tells me it's not likely
to be
okay so we're we're almost up to the
present day like that was a big leap to
become eukaryotic and get mitochondria
but uh for better for worse there's a
still you know family resemblance
between the energetics of the krebs
cycle in our cells today and this early
chemistry that that you're talking about
um but as biology does biology is very
opportunistic and you know it uses
things for for different things and now
the krebs cycle is playing all these
different roles so we're winding down
but say a little bit about um
where we are in terms of aging or cancer
or things like that so there's basically
there's there's this paradox then about
the krebs cycle it does two things
it started out making the carbon
skeletons for growth
so it was it was providing the
precursors to make amino acids to make
nucleotides whatever it is it's
basically biosynthetic it's making stuff
um but today
we're using it you know if you read
about it in textbooks is going to say is
used for burning things it's used for
respiration we're stripping the hydrogen
out of food and we're burning with
oxygen and whether it's one restriction
from food or stripping from the krebs
cycle intermediates themselves
but actually we're doing both
um and that puts quite a pressure on how
the mitochondrial work
so
if you've got good functional
mitochondria
you can do both at the same time
but
as things run down over time it gets
harder and harder to do both and then
instead of having a kind of continuous
flux going through the cycle it begins
to to
wear down a little bit i suppose you can
get flux going in the opposite direction
like the bacteria and this happens in
cancer it was discovered 10 years ago
that
where you're seeing reverse flux through
parts of the krebs cycle and
the work that i've been doing on this is
to do with uh fruit flies
and and how their mitochondria work
and what we found is that
how well they grow and how fertile they
are and things like that depends on how
good their respiration is if they
respire well then the krebs cycle goes
turning along and everything's
hunky-dory um
and they're they're capable of providing
enough energy that they need to to power
everything to to do their courtship
dancers they they they
they're
great fun to watch these these fruit
flies
um
but they
they're also capable of growing using
the krebs cycle intermediates to make
more cell membranes to make more
proteins to make more dna and rna and so
on so you need to do those two things
and what we know from cancer
is that
the atp is perhaps the less important of
the two things that you need to grow is
you know if you want to make two cells
from one cell you need some atp
but actually you also need a lot of
proteins you need a lot of dna you need
a lot of cell membranes there's a lot of
materials that you need to make two
cells from one cell you're doubling your
materials
and the krebs cycle is providing a lot
of that material so you've got this
tension there between making the energy
you need
not necessarily to double the cell
content but to to live to to to run
around to do stuff
to do a courtship dance in the case of
these fruit flies and so on um at the
same time you need to make stuff you
need to make
more cells
um
and
and it depends on how good your
aspiration is in the end as we get older
and respiration begins to run down a
little bit and notice we get less good
at doing the two things at the same time
and you end up doing one or the other
and the problem here then is as we get
older the krebs cycle begins to swing
into reverse
and begins to
we get less energy and more growth in
effect um we slow down and we put on
weight and
and it's all about flux through the
krebs cycle so the last chapters in the
book are about
why is this happening and again it's
thermodynamics in the end it's really
just about we are
we're doing you know a billion reactions
a second in every cell more than up to
20 billion reactions a second in every
cell if some of them go wrong and are
not repaired
we do this second after second after
second after second
over time proteins get damaged we know
that this is not a sexy theory for for
aging but it's been around a long time
and what we've found is that as
respiration becomes slightly damaged the
krebs cycle starts to go the opposite
into reverse
and that gives you a growth phenotype
which is a little bit like what cancer
cells are doing um which is to say it's
making more stuff it's making more fats
it's making more membranes it's making
more cells we begin to put on weight we
begin to have less energy we slow down
we don't want to go for the run which
might help our krebs cycle kind of go
back into the forwards direction and so
on um
and
and and this becomes an epigenetic state
this
flux state is reinforced in the activity
of the genes then effectively
the krebs cycle intermediates bleeding
out of the mitochondria are saying
uh to to the genes
um
don't worry about
making lots of energy worry about making
more fatty acids worry about bulking up
um and it's not a it's not a sustainable
situation in the end
so we run down
does this set of insights suggests any
solutions is there a krebs cycle diet
that will be your next self-help book uh
that will help people
run their kept cycles in the right way
um
i
it doesn't obviously i think the the
only solutions that that come to my mind
the things that people do anyway
uh and things things that i've started
doing more as i'm finding myself in my
mid 50s and i was you know in my 40s i
was putting on weight and
and slowing down a bit and spent too
much time at my desk and i'm beginning
to realize the only way to make my kev
cycle go forwards is eat less and run
more
and and that you're not going to make
any money with this book sorry this is
not going no no it's not that much about
yourself all the people out there who
are doing that anyway you're going to
love it but they're already doing it so
they're not going to learn anything and
the people who don't want to
don't want to make their krebs cycle
work in the right way are going to be
angry with me all right uh here's the
final question
most of when you've been talking about
um perhaps because this is your interest
but certainly also mine the origin of
life question and how these things come
in
um
terribly unfair but how close are we to
figuring this out i mean is this a
matter of like 100 years from now we'll
hope to have a complete picture or do
you think that progress is coming along
sufficiently rapidly that people will
come together i mean i've noticed
anecdotally that uh folks in the origin
of life community especially senior
people tend to disagree with each other
quite uh quite
energetically in various ways we're not
we're not a consensus yet
uh we're a long long way from a
consensus and um
yeah there's not much love lost in in
that field it's uh it's
it's hard actually and not i wish it
wasn't like that and i tried not to be
like that but maybe some people will say
i am like that but i don't want to be um
but anyway the point is
we'll never know how life started on
earth
which is to say
it that's a historical question
um and you can make a time machine and
go back and then what are you going to
look for where are you going to go are
you going to go to a terrestrial
geothermal system are you going to go to
a deep sea hydrothermal vent and if you
see some kind of slime on the walls of
this thing
what are you going to analyze is it live
yet or is it not yet is this a failed
experiment in the origin of life or was
this one that worked you know it's it as
a historical question it makes no sense
at all it's pointless um what we can do
is understand intellectually how a
sterile wet rocky planet is capable of
giving rise to living things
and we can try and think through all of
the steps and we can try and demonstrate
each one
um
that really it can happen that each step
can happen the idea that we can then put
all of those steps together and and do a
fineman and make life
uh i understand it now because i can
make it um
i don't see that happening at all right
certainly no time soon you know there's
some people out there saying we'll be
able to do it in five years time but if
you read the small print really what
they mean is uh well i can make some
kind of prototype thing which is capable
of copying itself but it's not really
life as we know it
um
what gave rise to life as a planet
on a planetary scale
these events that i talked about were
probably across the entire sea floor of
the early earth we're dealing with i i
refer to the earth as a battery um it's
a giant battery and the the flow of
energy and matter through this battery
uh
or what's animating cells today and
we're dealing with planetary forces the
idea that in the lab
with our poultry facilities we would be
capable of
producing cells that a planet
i don't know how many
how many nanoseconds it took the planet
to do this but probably quite a lot um
but maybe only a few million years
but the idea that we would be able to do
it i don't think it's realistic that
we're ever going to create life but i
think that what we can do is understand
and demonstrate the
believability of the steps
that
it's possible that a planet gives rise
to life in this way
and i think that's something to aspire
to yeah it sounds like an appropriately
humble goal in what is after all a
pretty hubristic uh pursuit over overall
so
nick lane thanks so much for being on
the mindscape podcast this is great
great pleasure thank you
[Music]
you